[Musique]
alors les chéris c'est très simple
aujourd'hui c'est un concours de
t-shirts mouillés avec tous les garçons
et vous allez décider chez vous qui aura
fait le meilleur défier les filles vous
allez vous mettre ici à me répéter vous
ici et vous allez regarder et vous allez
devoir arroser les garçons benhaim
enlevez moi c'est oui merci vous prenez
chacune un passionné allez-y prenez
chacune un pistolet vous y allez je vous
prenez les bombes à eau direct et chacun
des gars on va partir oui vous partie
chacun votre tour et vous allez devoir
nous faire le meilleur le meilleur des
filets et motels bon de vous mouiller
d'accord les chéris vous êtes sensuelle
vous êtes vous pouvez laisser les micros
pour l'instant apprise en voilà les
chéris attention est ce qu attend son
association ni chéri quand je vous le
dis est ce que vous êtes prêts ouais
ouais on va voir déjà le premier le
premier arrivant le 1er je vais demander
à christophe carrière de démarrer mais
venez venez plus prévient attention
christophe carrière c'est parti l'image
est reine dans les bureaux chez vous un
peu
[Musique]
mais l'an passé près
[Rires]
d'accord j'aimerais n'est pas christophe
carrière alors les filles comment la
trouvez très bien ton sang des mois
passés du rêve au cauchemar
une tarnaise numéro 2 allée à temps
presse
merci
mais
bien
[Musique]
jamais
non c est pas mal à habiter ce trajet
l'eau et le corps et pour une surprise
très beau corps gisant dans l'eau mais
attention on va passer à maxime galy
benjamin castaldi passé on avait dit
allez benji
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est prêt
pas mal c'est le même
[Musique]
benjamin castaldi laiterie des grilles
aux majorités les trois les trois sont
très beaux oiseaux très très différé
mecs vont m'impressionner
et vous êtes en forme franchement les
téléspectateurs et les téléspectatrices
sais pas ce qu'ils en pensent je les
trouve très très bon les trois comme ça
en blanc on va passer j'imagine le
gagner jean michel merle terminera par
le coup attention c'est parti on y va
jean-michel réunifier la beauté
abonnements
ce jour là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous avons arrêté tout arrive à tous il
a rien comprends pas si c'est un
concours de t-shirts et je respecte mes
barres et et me cracher dessus allez
aller chercher mieux merci mais il a
donné un copain jean michel aulas a
franchement bravo jeune fille
ça ne m'est pas illégal du mandat non
mais non c'est rien ça attention il est
vrai on va terminer
alors comment vous l'avez trouvé jean
michel maire qui nous plaît pas tout en
même temps je sois meilleur quoi un peu
trop arrogant un peu trop tôt mais le
meilleur c'est parce que vous allez
devoir choisir deux mois qu'ils vont
faire ensuite une dernière danse finale
devant vous attention le dernier maxime
gagné c'est parti
mala pas mal
pas mal pas mal autant ça marche cette
merde
[Musique]
seule l'action gagne c'est un des
lycéens sadc pluies deviendront alors
les shérifs hawks et vous allez devoir
chacune en sauver deux d'agrément faire
une dernière danse attention géraldine
maillet moi je sauve benjamin castaldi
oui gilles verdez j'ai vu pareille
benjamin gille vos pareils benjamin
gille et vous jean-mi pour la générosité
et gilles pour la bonne surprise vient
donc c'est pas jamais jamais jamais à
chaud vous avez de la chance vous aurez
la chance était benjamin et gilles et on
va prendre quelqu'un en qui va désigner
son favori du public au plus quatre ans
d'art on à charlotte en ligne s'allume à
charlotte
comment tu les trouveras sur l'autre
franchement ils sont très nettement
voilà on est dehors rockliffe un peu
savent agents mis ses bons mettez vous
sur le côté regretté josé merci à céret
à ton avis qui va gagner auprès des 6 au
concours de t-shirt mouillé il
jude alors attention mais elle pense que
c'est gênant mais vous devez vous allez
être attention c'est parti
vous allez le voir faire une dernière
danse mais là vous donner tout ce que
vous avez
non ça car autour ça les fatigue loi
fait le saut ramazzotti matelas ensemble
on les moineaux censé parquet va bien je
vous l'aimiez attention 3,2 à ces
particules
ouais
[Musique]
arrivé tellement plus loin
allez y
[Musique]
à
trop bien
[Musique]
ça va pas bien arrêtez tout arrêter tous
les chérit les geler si les filles
venaient là où défilent jeunes est là
pour vous et lute lute il encore
posséder à est encore en train de danser
chez vous je crois qu'avant mais c'est
n'importe quoi
les chutes les chérit les céréales et
donnez moi ces domaines et moi ces
pistolets vous avez encore de l'eau
c'est bon c'est bon ah oui voila voila
merci disperser la foule merci merci les
séries merci oui alors les cherry à
votre avis à votre avis qui a été
brillant qui était meilleure pour moi
c'est gilles pour moi selon les zones et
benji pour vous pour moi c'est gilles
même si c'est gênant quand il danse bobo
cgil
il a tout donné on va faire mieux gérad
il est bien ma chérie tu repars avec un
magnifique cadeau c'est quoi le cadeau
dirige à me dire ça il le sait pas non
il m'a bien ramène toi c'est quoi ces
tablettes au shérif dans mes oreilles
d'accord une tablette tu paries qu'une
tablette mcsherry merkava